I'm glad you had a chance to come out on
this beautiful weekend and yeah what I'd
like to do today is tell you a little
bit about the research i do the things
that i think about and that excite me
that keep me up at night as Kurt
mentioned I'm a physics faculty I'm a
researcher I'm a lecturer and what I'll
talk to you about is some of the
questions that have yeah followed me and
inspired me probably for the last 20 or
30 years since since I was a kid like
yes some some of you here so what I'll
talk about neutrinos universe and goes
particles who has heard about the
universe everyone yeah who is heard
about ghosts yes everyone has heard
about ghosts has anyone heard about
neutrinos yet Oh excellent she seems
like we have some experts here so when
we think about the universe most of the
time you think about a picture like this
you think about stars you think about
clouds and you think about pretty
structures if you take a telescope and
you can go up to the light now
Observatory here on signed sealed and on
a clear day look through the telescope
you might even see some more structure
in there you might see something like
galaxies like the galaxies that we live
in a collection of stars and clouds that
yeah we find in our universe now if you
take a really powerful telescope like
some of the astronomers and some of the
colleagues that we have here on campus
you might see something like this this
is a picture taken with the Hubble Space
Telescope that looks very deep into
space it looks at very faint stars and
what you can see there is it's not quite
as crisp st
previous image but you see lots of
little stars you see the structure of
galaxies and all of these things you can
see essentially with with your eye as
long as your power your telescope is
your powerful enough if you take a very
broad look if you take step back and
look at the universe and you look at all
the things that are in the universe then
it might actually look like this the
universe is not a homogeneous place it's
a place where you have structures where
you have collection of galaxies and this
is what we think the large-scale
structure of the universe might actually
look like so it's almost like this
spiderweb type of thing and you have
your clusters of matter of stuff that's
yeah in the universe now all of these
things are studied with astronomy
essentially what astronomers do is they
take the telescope sometimes very
powerful telescope and they look into
the universe so if you take a telescope
whether it's on earth or in space you
can essentially look back in time you
look at galaxies and you look at the
light that comes from the very early
universe and so what these telescopes do
is they see a cross section of the
visible universe now what I am doing is
I'm not an astronomer I'm a particle
astrophysicist I'm interested in
connecting the very big universe to the
very small and basically what I'm
interested in is understanding how the
very tiny things that make up matter
that make up us affect the large scale
of the universe who has heard about
atoms and nuclei so basically the stuff
that we are made of the structure of
matter consists of atoms atoms you can
think about it it's like a like a little
ball or something but it has structure
inside and
inside these atoms we find things like
electrons we find neutrons and protons
these are particles nucleons that make
up Adams and we find even smaller
structure so the research that I do is
trying to understand the structure
inside the matter that makes up galaxies
that makes up humans that makes up stars
and so to do this we go very deep inside
these atoms and for those of you who
want to get a sense of the scale how
deep inside we go if this is an atom
then the structures inside are really
really tiny the neutrons and protons
that make up the atom are about one
ten-thousandth of the size of an atom
and then you go even further and the
quirks that make up neutrons and protons
the little parts inside these neutrons
and protons they are 100 millions of the
size so it gets small very very quickly
so the research we do is essentially
looking into atoms looking into nuclei
understanding the structure and trying
to relate it to the big universe and
what we see in yeah in the universe
nowadays now you might ask so where do
neutrinos come in it turns out that
matter is made out of building blocks
it's like a Lego set you know you have
your yellow lego you have your red lego
you have your blue legal and you put
them all together and you can build
things and that's how we think about it
we have what's called elementary
particles these elementary particles are
the building blocks of mavin and among
these elementary particles they are
there's a group of particles that are
called neutrinos and these are the
things that I'll be telling you about
and why they excite us and why they are
your interesting to us now you don't
have to worry about the details here
just remember that they actually three
different kinds of neutrinos and we'll
get back to that it's like you're having
three flavors of ice cream now you might
wonder well if there are so many LEGO
pieces why do we care about neutrinos
well neutrinos are really special in
many ways first of all they're really
lots of them their billions of them the
other thing is neutrinos almost move at
the speed of light you may have heard
that the fastest we can go on the
universe is at the speed of light and
neutrinos almost reach that no one else
can be as fast as light in neutrinos
turns out that neutrinos almost have no
mass they are almost like light but not
not quite and the fourth point is that
neutrinos are really very weakly
interacting they can go through
everything they can go through you they
can go through the earth they can go
through stars and so what we do is we
use neutrinos the things that we can't
see to explore what I call the invisible
universe so first on the point of how
many neutrinos they are everyone like
know what a cubic centimeter is it's
like a sugar cube so take a sugar cube
and in this volume of space you have an
average in the universe 330 neutrinos so
in every little QP and it turns out that
this is actually quite a bit because
this is a billion times more than we
have protons the other things that make
up nuclei and matter so if they're
billion more neutrinos and protons in
the universe you ask well what role do
neutrinos play are the important or do
we care and this is what we are trying
to get answer with the work yeah that we
do now turns out that there are lots of
neutrinos but they have very little mass
and if you take all the neutrinos in the
universe and compare them to
stars it turns out that they're almost
as many neutrinos as is mass in stars so
the next time you step outside at night
you look at the sky you look at all the
stars you might see the Milky Way if
you're in a really dark spot imagine
there's as much up there in terms of
neutrinos that we can't see but that are
all around us but even though there's so
much up there in terms of neutrinos it
turns out it's only a really small
fraction of the universe turns out that
the stars and neutrinos are less than a
percent of the entire universe most of
the universe is dark and it consists of
stuff that we can't see and we don't
even know what it is and physicists and
astronomers have given it names like
dark matter and dark energy because we
really have no clue what it is but we
know it is out there so if you look at
this figure here this pie chart the
stuff that we are made of and the stuff
that we see is this little sliver the
rest of the universe is still unexplored
and so it's really up to you when you
grow up and hopefully you'll become
scientist then you can figure out what
all the rest is I don't think we'll
learn this in my lifetime now I said
that the adrenals are really weakly
interacting particles well what does
this really mean so I decided to consult
SMI expert and this is a quote from
Douglas Adams mostly a harmless and he
actually wrote in this book about
neutrinos and he said well it would be
an unusual nanosecond in which the earth
was not hit by several billion passing
neutrinos it all depends on what you
mean by hit of course because seeing as
matter consists of almost entirely
nothing at all so what is he saying he's
saying that there's really not much that
makes up matter that it's a lot of empty
space
and he goes on to say the chances of a
neutrino actually hitting something as
it travels through space or through this
emptiness it's the same as dropping a
ball from an airplane and hitting an egg
sandwich as someone is walking by on
earth now let me just illustrate what he
really means by that so this is this is
what it's like so just imagine you have
all these neutrinos around you and you
ask yourself are they going to hit you
so it's like dropping a ball from an
airplane and it it drops and drops it
gets closer to Earth and then you just
imagine you are having lunch and walking
by and flip so what is the chance of
this happening so next time you walk
with your plate outside and you see an
airplane flying to New York think about
it if someone opens the window and drop
the ball would they hit you it's very
very very unlikely and this is how
unlikely it is for a neutrino to hit
anything in you or in other matter now
if you can see that with with all of
this neutrinos are pretty special there
are lots of them out there they move at
the speed of light but they really don't
hit very much and this means that with
neutrinos we can not only explore the
universe that we can see galaxies but we
can go back in time and our theory is
that about 14 billion years ago the
universe started with a big bang it was
a essentially a big explosion of energy
and the universe expanded after that and
in the very early times
maybe a second or minutes after the
explosion the universe was just a big
soup a big super soft stuff and it was
so thick that not even light could come
out and light could only come out very
much later but with these neutrinos that
are so weakly interacting we can
actually go back in time and probe the
very early universe now you might ask
well all of these neutrinos that I've
taught telling you about so where do
they come from well it turns out that
neutrinos mostly come from what we call
nuclear reaction so you have a nucleus
and Adam that decays it falls apart and
when it falls apart breaks apart we get
some other particles out some other
stuff and amongst this stuff there are
these neutrinos now it turns out that
this falling apart happens in many
places in nature we have neutrinos that
were created at the beginning of time in
the Big Bang and those are left over in
space and I mentioned there about 300
per cubic centimeter we have neutrinos
that come from exploding stars so when a
stock comes to the end of its life it
goes through a process that ends in
what's called a supernova an explosion
and neutrinos can be produced in this
process we have neutrinos that come from
high-energy cosmic rays from space we
have neutrinos that come from the Sun so
you can look at the Sun and you not only
get light out of it but you get all of
these neutrinos because they come from
the nuclear reactions inside the Sun and
then it turns out we have also neutrinos
that are produced in the atmosphere we
have neutrinos that come from inside the
earth even and we have man-made
neutrinos from accelerators reactors and
things like that so there are all sorts
of neutrinos
around us now the scientific story of
the neutrino started in nineteen thirty
there was a scientist called Wolfgang
Pauli and he was studying these nuclear
decays and he was looking at what
happens when a nucleus decays and what
you get out and there was something that
just didn't quite make sense it puzzled
him he couldn't add up yeah all the
energy that came out of it and so he did
something that at the time was quite
surprising he just said you know there
has to be another particle involved at
the time we didn't know that there were
all of these different building blocks
of matter that there were all of these
LEGO pieces so he postulated this and
then it took some experimentalist some
25 years to actually verify this and it
was rynason town that built an
experiment they essentially took a big
tank filled it with liquid and they put
it next to a nuclear reactor where you
have lots of these nuclear reactions
that produce entry nose and then they
found that indeed these neutrinos came
out of nuclear nuclear reactions and
they sent a telegram to poly and at the
time they didn't have email of course
all the web and poly wrote back well
thanks for the message everything comes
to him who knows how to wait so 25 years
after he had said well there has to be
this building block they have to be
neutrinos there was the experimental
observation and one of the things to
take away from this is sometimes science
takes a long time but in the end you'll
get the answer so as long as you're
patient you'll get yeah the right answer
and this was the beginning of a research
field that is now growing and keeping us
occupied and will keep us occupied for
decades to come so in the 70s people got
more sophisticated they actually managed
to image the interaction of neutral
so this is an image from a so called
bubble chamber it's a little bit like
the cloud chamber that you may have seen
outside where you can look at cosmic
rays going through so they have they
built a bubble chamber and you had a new
channel coming in and it interacted with
other matter in this chamber and you've
got other particles coming out and then
you see the tracks of these particles
and so so this is the first image of a
neutrino interaction in a detector and
nowadays we have built very
sophisticated detectors so we can really
map the structure and particles that
come out of these yeah interactions so
how do we actually do this I've told you
about the universe there are lots of
neutrinos but how do we actually learn
about them so the first thing we have to
do is we have to go to a place where we
can study neutrinos and that for us
involves going deep underground most of
my professional life I've spent
underground in mines in underground
laboratories I've I've not seen the
sunlight and this has to do with the
fact that they're all these cosmic rays
coming down from space so if you take a
look at the cloud chamber outside you
see these tracks of particles these are
cosmic rays the just impinge on us from
space and this is yeah illustrated here
now if I build a detector and I just let
it sit here the only thing I would see a
cosmic rays but I would not see these
very faint feeble neutrinos and so to do
that we have to go underground and
literally what we do is we seek the
darkest deepest places on earth where we
can build our experiment the very first
experiment that I worked on worse in a
nickel mine in Ontario Canada we went
6800 feet underground with all the
miners and they built us a a room about
ten stories high and underground and we
built an experiment there
so for yes some seven years I went
underground almost daily like this and I
put on a suit and I have my mining
certificate so physics doesn't work out
I can go mining in Canada and we did
yeah physics experiments there this is
what we built down there this is six to
eight hundred feet underground it's a 10
story building that houses what's called
the Sudbury neutrino Observatory and
basically it was a detector that had a
big spheres filled with water and then
lots of sensors light sensors on the
outside so when in your Chino hits the
detector it produces light that we can
then see in this experiment now this is
what it looked like after we had
completed it it's this gigantic ya 18
meter diameter and yes fear and you can
see a fisheye view here and basically
what happens is the neutrino because
it's so weakly interacting it can go
through the earth it's not stopped all
the cosmic rays are stopped by the 6800
feet of ground above us but the neutrino
goes through and when the neutrino hits
the water in this detector then it
produces some light that week we can see
so again what we do here is we build a
detector that allows us to see the
visible light from the invisible
neutrino and then we put it on a
computer this display and this is
actually what it looks like this is a
signature of a neutrino six to eight
hundred feet underground from the Sun
and of course people have gotten very
ambitious this is a picture of a similar
neutrino detector in Japan again it's
underneath a mountain in an old mine and
what you are looking at here is a very
large Cabot
she filled or instrumented with all of
these photo sensors and this was during
the process when they were filling it
with water it was so large that people
had to take a boat to to float and
service all of these photo sensors so
this is a cavity about 50 meters high I
think 30 meter diameters and it's now
filled completely with water and when a
neutrino goes through there again it
produces this light that we can see with
all of these photo sensors on the wall
this is what they have measured who
recognizes at least one of these
pictures what are you looking at yes
what do you see there want to say hmm
okay yes yeah yes it is the Sun this is
the Sun how everyone sees it you step
outside in the morning or evening and
you see the Sun this is the Sun as seen
in ultraviolet light or x-rays so if you
an astronomer if you fly satellite this
is what you might see this is the Sun
six to eight hundred feet underground in
neutrino light so basically what I like
to tell my students and people who work
with me of course you'll see the Sun
when you do research with me just look
at the neutrinos so so this is a picture
that was taken with one of these
detectors looking at the neutrinos
coming from the Sun but you're deep and
underground to get away from all the
cosmic rays so it going deep underground
is not enough for ya some of the
research that we do and some of the
experiments that we've built it even
more remote places like for example the
South Pole and this is a picture of
Antarctica and the South Pole is yep
very much in the middle and this is what
the view the aerial view from this looks
like at the South Pole when you actually
travel there you fly in by airplane and
you have the u.s. South Pole Station and
you have lots of buildings and supplies
there you have an airstrip a runway
where you land and then you have several
different experiments and some of them
are also looking for neutrinos and you
might wonder well why do we go to the
South Pole it's pretty far away it's
even more remote than just going
underground and it turns out it's a
place where again you can put your
detector and deep underground to get
away from cosmic rays it's a very quiet
place you don't have much disturbing
radiation and you get all the water but
I told you about in our detectors for
free it's just in frozen form so so what
was done at the South Pole is the
following they've built a neutrino
detector two and a half kilometers deep
into the Antarctic ice and so when you
go to the South Pole this is what you
see on top it's essentially a hot frozen
over where all the electronics is and
then they have drilled holes a mile and
a half deep into the ice and they have
placed these photo sensors that I
mentioned and now neutrinos that come
from space they can go through the eyes
and again they can create this light and
this light can travel through the anarki
guys because the anak you guys is very
pure and then it can be picked up by
these photo sensors so that's another
way of detecting neutrinos you just use
the Antarctic ice shield essentially as
your your detector so one of the things
that I just wanted to emphasize is your
trainers are so weakly interacting they
go through everything they go through us
they go through stars
they can go through the earth it doesn't
matter whether you on one side of the
earth or the other the neutrinos just go
right through just remember the ball
bearing dropping from the airplane
that's what the neutrino sees as it
approaches yours it's essentially
nothing the earth is nothing so and this
is the reason why we can also see in
your tree nose from some very
spectacular cosmic events super novae I
exploding stars so at the end of the
life of a star it gets very dense and
then it explodes and it turns out that
initially it's so dense the light can't
come out but the neutrinos can so the
first signature that we get from an
exploding star essentially neutrinos
coming to Earth and astronomers are
looking for it they are trying to see
the neutrinos first and then point the
telescope at the sky to detect the later
light from exploding stars I also
mentioned that neutrinos come from
inside the earth and I just wanted to
say a couple of words about that again
inside the earth you have nuclei nuclei
that decay it actually turns out that
the decays of nuclei in the earth are
the ones that give the heat that he heat
up your earth and so we can see
neutrinos that come from the mantle and
crust of the earth and this is a picture
that shows you the neutrinos it coming
from inside so where there's continents
you have many more neutrinos coming out
then were there is ocean it also turns
out that neutrinos come from nuclear
reactors because you have nuclear
reactions in there and this is where a
lot of my research is taking place we
just go near nuclear reactors commercial
power plants because all the neutrinos
are coming out and we can place our
experiments and study the properties of
neutrinos and this is what the neutrino
landscape
the neutrino world map looks like in
terms of react on your tree nose so this
figure shows you the distribution of
neutrinos from reactors in the world and
you can see clearly the countries and
the regions where there are lots of
reactors Europe the US and of course
Asia and Japan had a lot of reactors
before they were shut down now what have
we learned now one of the things that we
learned which was quite fundamental
about yeah 13 14 years ago that
neutrinos even though they almost move
at the speed of light they do have a
tiny little bit of mass and so they make
up part of the mass of the universe and
this has some really interesting
consequences we initially thought that
neutrinos essentially come in three
flavors like or three colors like blue
yellow and green now it turns out that
this is not really the case because
neutrinos have mass they have a very
strange phenomenon and that is that they
can change color so instead of thinking
about your tree nodes and three colors
we now have to think about neutrinos in
terms of being a mixture of something
and if I take a jelly bean from one of
these jars I don't know what I get a
blue yellow or green neutrino and this
is a phenomenon this is a quantum
mechanical phenomenon that is a direct
result of the fact that neutrinos have
mass so this transformation of neutrinos
takes place over space and time so when
a neutrino is created it travels through
space it might start out as a yellow one
but then it turns into a green or blue
blue one and I have a couple of yet
demonstrations to illustrate this and
it's a little bit like sound and let me
just show this to you
so imagine our neutrino is like a sound
wave this is one kind let's say this is
this is the yellow neutrino
the blue neutrino has a slightly
different tone but it's also there all
the time if you hear them separately you
can't really say that this one is 401
hurts the other one is 400 Hertz they
almost sound the same now what I do is I
put both of these neutrinos together and
let's see what happens to neutrinos were
slightly different colors or slightly
different sound I get this weird beat
pattern and this is essentially what
happens with neutrinos the yellow
neutrino appears and disappears and
appears and disappears and the same with
the blue neutrino it appears and
disappears and this is what we call
neutrino oscillations neutrinos are
really waves they almost like sound and
the different colors are represented by
the different yet tones here and this is
the reason why we can't really say well
there is just one color of neutrinos or
the other it continuously changes and
this was yeah one of the important
things that we discovered about 14 years
ago now let me just take a few more
minutes to tell you a little bit about
well why this matters what why do we
care about neutrinos I mean we can't see
them we have to go underground to look
at them so why do we go through all of
this and this has to do with one big
questions and physics and cosmology that
we can't answer yet and that has to do
why do we live in a universe of matter
now the idea is that at the very
beginning of time there was this big
bang and in physics we always have
matter and antimatter we have particles
and antiparticles for every particle we
have something that's opposite and if
you bring them together they annihilate
they create energy I'm sure you've heard
about it in Star Wars and other if we
could only bring matter and antimatter
together we would have solved our energy
crisis I mean that's that's for sure so
the question now is if in the beginning
of time there was this big bang when we
created almost equal amounts of matter
and antimatter why are we here why
haven't we annihilated with the anti
part of our self and so there has to be
a certain imbalance and we are trying to
understand where this imbalance comes
from so 14 billion years ago we think
there was an almost equal amount of
matter and antimatter but if you look at
the universe nowadays well what we see
is there's matter there galaxies they're
human beings there's the earth so we are
just the ones that are left over us but
the anti-us doesn't exist and so it
turns out that to answer this question
neutrinos may play a fundamental role
and one of the questions that has to do
with this is that neutrinos may be there
on anti particles and to do this we're
now mounting experiments that look at
properties of neutrinos and again we're
going deep underground this is an
experiment in Italy where we sit
literally sit underneath this mountain
to get away from cosmic rays and we look
at nuclear decays to figure out if
neutrinos and antineutrinos are the same
particles and we also are starting to
plan a
experiments that try to look at the
change of neutrinos and antineutrinos
over distance it's a very ambitious
project in the u.s. that wants to shoot
a neutrino and an anti neutrino beam
from Chicago to a mine in South Dakota
and this is over a thousand kilometers
and we could see how the neutrinos
change and it all has to do with the
fact well we want to understand if
neutrinos and antineutrinos are the same
thing or not now let me come to the end
and leave you with perhaps one thing and
this is ok we want to understand if
neutrinos are they on anti particles and
this is probably one of the most
important questions in in our field so a
neutrino physics i should say is a big
effort it's a collaborative effort you
can imagine that these detectors that i
showed you take a lot of people to build
a lot of students a lot of postdocs and
so usually we work in a group of people
and this is one of the things that I
found fascinating in science we get a
chance to work with people all over the
world I've gone to Antarctica China
Italy and Japan just to study neutrinos
and it's when you work with people all
over the world that that's when you
combine signs in scientific endeavor
with also your social interactions and
it becomes very inspiring and fun thing
yeah to do now at the very end let me
leave you with one thing and that is
that there's so many neutrinos everyone
take up their thumb so you see your
thumb if you look at your thumb for one
second you have billion billions of
neutrinos going through it and they go
right through your body and they don't
hurt you but there are as much matter in
the universe as all the stars you see in
the sky
so thank you and I'm around to take
questions